Well, my chess career really began in California.
My brother was a junior player when he was quite young...
..and so, because of that, he would go and play tournaments...
...around the United States and I would end up going along.
And through that, I just sort of, just by being around chess,...
...I got into the game and eventually I started playing it.
I think it's very different.
For me, I was homeschooled,...
...which gave me many opportunities to travel around the country...
...also to travel a lot in Europe to compete...
...against some of the best kids in the world.
And so, because of this, I had the opportunity to see a lot of different cultures,...
...meet a lot of different people,...
...whereas had I not played chess,...
...I probably would have only been exposed to people...
...from similar backgrounds as myself and only in America.
So, I think it really broadened my horizons.
And I think it doesn't matter what sport you play,...